remember earlier this week when kourtney
kardashian's ex eunice benjamin called
out her other ex scott disick over an
alleged direct message he claimed he
received from the reality star bashing
court's new relationship with travis
barker yeah well now a source tells e.t
court's not happy with scott
courtney and travis don't care about
scott's opinion but courtney is upset
it's now public i've seen it all the
source adds that scott and courtney who
share three children together have
always had a public united front and
have done a great job co-parenting
court's frustration here according to
the source is because she always tries
to protect the little ones from what's
said publicly about their family quote
courtney doesn't want her kids seeing
anything online that makes it look like
their parents don't get along courtney
has always been conscious of being
private in past relationships but she's
done caring what others think and is
enjoying love with travis
i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens just in case
you missed the drama it all went down
monday night after the 28 year old model
who dated court on and off for years
prior to her current relationship with
the blank 182 drummer took to his insta
story to share a screenshot of dms he
claims were from scott allegedly scott
sent eunice a pic of courtney and travis
engaging in some major pda during their
italian vacation and allegedly wrote
yo is this chick okay bro like what is
this in the middle of italy eunice's
response quote doesn't matter to me as
long as she's happy p.s i ain't your bro
and eunice he added a note to the
screenshot quote keep the same energy
you had about me publicly privately of
course scott expressed his dislike for
eunice during the keeping up with the
kardashians reunion special back in june
oh the last guy let's all be honest
nobody was happy with the last one so
really yeah scott and everyone else
i was still there to try to help her
through
but during that same special scott gave
courtney his blessing to be happy in her
new relationship with travis i think if
you really love somebody right like you
want them to be happy no matter what so
i do give her a blessing to be happy
but a source previously told et that
scott has always been a little salty and
upset about court's current relationship
quote he doesn't love thinking or
talking about it he tries to focus on
his own life as much as possible but
sometimes it feels like it's in his face
and hard to avoid seeing courtney and
travis get more and more serious and her
move on in this intense way has been a
bit of a sore subject
[Music]